.
DAGEN.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
AFTER IGNORING THE BORDER
CRISIS FOR YEARS, LIBERAL MEDIA
OUTLETS ARE SLAMMING FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS FOR
SENDING TWO PLANES OF MIGRANTS
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
MSNBC HOST CHRIS HAYES TWEETED
DEEPLY SICK AND DEHUMANIZING TO
FLING HUMAN BEINGS VIN
DIKTIVELY.
ANOTHER ONE SAYING DESANTIS
HEARTLESSNESS AND CYNICISM IS
HARD TO EXAGGERATE.
KEITH OEL BERMAN CALL IT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
READING TALKING POINTS.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, SO BASED ON
FACTS, THEN JOE BIDEN IS A
HUMAN TRAFFICKER AS WELL
BECAUSE THEY HAVE DONE THE SAME
THING FLYING MIGRANTS UNDER THE
COVER OF NIGHT TO PLACES LIKE
NEW YORK STATE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WESTCHESTER IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT OR FLORIDA.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR 18
MONTHS UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND SUDDENLY
THESE FOLKS CARE.
IF THEY CARED SO MUCH ABOUT THE
WELL-BEING OF ILLEGAL MIGRANTS,
DAGEN, THEY REALLY SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION TO THIS REPORT THAT
JUST CAME OUT FROM DHS.
AT LEAST 750 MIGRANTS HAVE DIED
TRYING TO CROSS INTO THE U.S.
YOU COMPARE THAT TO THE YEAR
BEFORE WHEN THE NUMBER WAS ONLY
200, RIGHT?
MANY OF THAT WAS FROM HEAT
EXPOSURE AND PEOPLE DROWNING
NOW.
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
19,000 SEARCH AND RESCUES BY
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ALONE.
THEY ARE RISKING THEIR LIVES AS
WELL.
RON DESANTIS IF HE IS PLAYING
CHESS DEMOCRATS ARE PLAYING
CHECKERS AND THE HYPOCRISY IS
IN THE OPENING AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY COVERING THE STORY.
>> OTHER NETWORKS ARE AT
MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
UNTIL RECENTLY YOU COULDN'T
FIND ANOTHER TELEVISION
REPORTER FROM A CABLE NETWORK
DOWN AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THAT'S BEEN THE STORY.
THAT IS THE STORY, NOT MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
BUT THEY ARE DOING -- THE MEDIA
AND DEMOCRATS ARE DOING EXACTLY
WHAT GOVERNOR ABBOTT IN
PARTICULAR EXPECTED THEM TO DO.
YOU HAVE TO PUT ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS AT THEIR DOORSTEP FOR
THEM TO START BEING UPSET ABOUT
WHAT IS A RUNAWAY CRISIS.
IT IS A FINANCIAL HARDSHIP FOR
ANYBODY AND EVERYBODY ACROSS
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, TEXAS,
ARIZONA, NEW MEXICO.
>> MORE THAN 4 MILLION PEOPLE
WILL HAVE CROSSED INTO THIS
COUNTRY IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS
OF THIS PRESIDENCY ALONE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NEARLY SIX
TIMES THE POPULATION OF BOSTON,
MASSACHUSETTS.
NOT TOO FAR FROM MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
THE STORY MOVED OFF MARTHA'S
THEY'VE BEEN MOVED TO CAPE COD
TO A MILITARY BASE.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD COULDN'T DEAL
WITH THEM.
>> WITH THE HYPOCRISY ALWAYS
COMES HYPERBOLE.
NEW DAY ON CNN.
>> ALL OF YOUR DOCUMENTARIES
ARE ABOUT HISTORY.
BUT ALL OF THEM ALSO MAKE YOU
THINK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE NOW
AND WE WOKE UP TO THE NEWS THIS
MORNING THAT GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS OF FLORIDA SENT TWO
PLANE LOADS OF MIGRANTS TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD WITH KIDS AND
WHAT NOT.
THIS IS NOT A PARALLEL HERE IN
ANY WAY BUT IT DOES ADDRESS
SOME OF THE SAME THEMES THAT
ARE PART OF THIS DOCUMENTARY.
>> WHAT?
THE HOLOCAUST?
>> JOHN BERMAN SHOULD KNOW
BETTER AND WHY HE IS BEING
DEMOTED.
WHENEVER THEY TALK ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST PROBABLY HAVEN'T READ
ABOUT IT.
HOW JEWS WEREN'T JUST
EXTERMINATED RIGHT AWAY, THEY
WORKED UNTIL THEY COULDN'T
PHYSICALLY DO IT ANYMORE AND
THERE WAS NO VALUE TO THE NAZIS
AND THEN THEY WERE EXTERMINATED.
YOU ARE COMPARING THIS TO THAT?
I DON'T GET ANGRY VERY OFTEN
BUT SCREW YOU, JOHN BERMAN, THE
WORST ANALOGY YOU COULD USE AND
INSULT TO EVERY SINGLE PERSON
THAT LOST A FAMILY MEMBER IN
THAT HORRIBLE HOLOCAUST.
>> YOU COULD CALL UP MY BEST
FRIENDS WHOSE DAD WAS IN A WORK
CAMP HIGHLY THE REST OF HIS
FAMILY WERE EXTERMINATED.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD SUCH A
HARDSHIP.
THE PEOPLE WANTED THE MIGRANTS
GONE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
THEY CAN'T POSSIBLY STAY HERE
SAID A WOMAN.
THE GREAT BIDEN INTERVIEW
DROUGHT, JOE CONCHA, CAME TO AN
END.
60 MINUTES TWEETED IT WILL AIR
AT SIT-DOWN INTERVIEW SUNDAY TO
KICK OFF THE SEASON.
BY SUNDAY BIDEN WILL HAVE GONE
219 DAYS WITHOUT A SIT-DOWN
INTERVIEW.
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
DEFENDED THE PRESIDENT WHEN
ASKED ABOUT IT LAST WIEK.
ONLY INTERVIEWED 22 TIMES
BETWEEN TAKING OFFICE AND MAY
OF THIS YEAR.
AT THE SAME POINT IN HIS TERM
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAT DOWN FOR 90
INTERVIEWS WITH THE MEDIA AND I
KNOW THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA SAT
DOWN FOR EVEN MORE THAN THAT.
187, I THINK.
>> THERE IS A REASON WHY HE IS
GOING ON 60 MINUTES.
A TAPED INTERVIEW.
THINGS CAN BE EDITED OUT.
60 MINUTES TWITTER FEED.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN TELLS 60
MINUTES WENT INTO THE DEAL THAT
STOPPED THE NATIONWIDE RAILROAD
STRIKE.
AMAZING TIMING.
JOE BIDEN SAT DOWN WITH HIM AT
THE VERY DAY THE CRISIS NO ONE
HEARD ABOUT THIS WEEK WAS
AVERTED.
IT WILL BE A FIXED FIGHT.
NOT THE 60 MINUTES WE GREW UP
WITH.
WE SAW IT WITH LESLEY STAHL AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTED TO
INVESTIGATE THE HUNTER BIDEN
STORY AND SAID THERE ISN'T
THERE THERE.
WE KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN LIED TO
GEORGE STEPHANOPOLOUS LA